perhaps to Best Actor so let's see which  one you like you really really like for  his role as a detective protecting an  Amish boy who has seen a murder Harrison  Ford in witness  as a small-town widower competing with  an ex-husband for the affections of a  young young ish Worsley James Garner in  Murphy's romance  the prisoner whose stories help him and  his cellmate escape to a world of  fantasy  appearing in his 39th film as the  slow-witted hitman who meets a  quick-witted hit woman Jack Nicholson  and Prizzi's honor  for his role as a hardened criminal who  escapes prison only to find himself on a  train bound for nowhere john-boy and  runaway train  the winner is the winner is William Hurt  I share this with Raul  ba boom ba boom ba boom it's it's  incredible I didn't expect to be here so  I don't know what I'm gonna say I want  to thank the courageous people in Brazil  with whom I made this film  Sall dodgy Brazil I am very proud to be  an actor thank you very much  you